happy father's day by the way to all the
dads happy father's day to you happy
father's day to everyone in the room all
the guys in the room happy father's day
to all the guys at home who have babies
um
wow what a day
uh my dad i'm gonna tell you a little
bit about my dad a little bit about my
husband but when i thought about
father's day yesterday i said well
we're not doing a show on father's day
but this is a topic near and dear to my
heart
because i had a very active dad in the
house like he was present he was very
present and i have a husband that's very
very present with our son
but i read all these studies all the
time about what happens in a fatherless
home and i know it's a topic people
don't like to discuss they don't feel
like it's woke enough you know everyone
wants to tell you oh you can do it alone
you don't need a man you don't need a
guy in the house that's not that
important
it actually is quite important um and of
course there's going to be people out
there single moms who find themselves in
circumstances that are less than ideal
who are doing an amazing job kicking
butt i get it i totally get it but we
also have to be realistic about the role
that dads play in children's lives and
i'm not just talking about sons i'm
talking about daughters and
what has the potential to happen if
there isn't a dad in the home there are
some concerns that have been
rising up there are some stats we need
to look at i'm not typically a stats
girl but i want to start today with some
mysterious stats on this issue because
this is an important one and we do have
an epidemic right now not just in this
country but in the world at large well
let's focus on this country of
fatherless homes so let's take a look at
some of these this is from the national
center for fathering and the fatherless
generation
and we got this from no longer
fatherless.org 85 percent of youths in
prison come from fatherless homes
71 of high school dropouts come from
fatherless homes 90 of all homeless and
runaway children are from fatherless
homes and 60 of youth suicides
are from fatherless homes so just take a
second and absorb that
as we talk about these big issues of
suicide we're always always on the brain
it's mental health and guns and you know
education and performance in classrooms
and all of these things think about all
of that
as we look at these statistics and i
have a lot more of these coming because
i think they're shocking they were for
me at least they may be for some of you
this is from the 2017 u.s census bureau
it came from parentspluskids.com
and i'm going to just go through a
couple of these the percentage of
children without a father in the u.s is
43 they mean with like an absentee
father
90 of runaway and homeless children are
from fatherless homes
70 of miners housed in state facilities
are from fatherless homes
if you go down a little bit into the
section called how a fatherless
generation affects education
71 percent of all high school dropouts
from fatherless homes the percentage of
minors in prison who grew up without a
father
85
this stuff blew my mind i knew it was a
problem did i know it was this much of a
problem i didn't i didn't
health related issues impacted by
fatherlessness
this is also from the 2017 u.s census
the percentage of adolescents in
substance abuse treatment facilities who
are from fatherless homes
75
71 of teenagers who are pregnant
pregnant teens come from a fatherless
home
63 of youth suicides happen in
households with an absent father 85
percent of children with behavioral
disorders are from homes without fathers
teen girls without a father are seven
times more likely to become pregnant as
a teenager
so again
think about all the things we talk about
all of these big issues
whether it's abortion whether it's crime
happening in cities
whatever it is
you always have to think about we always
talk about the family and the breakdown
of the family and what's going on in the
family and i always say bring every
issue down
back to your dinner table everything
happens at that community level right at
that dinner table is there a dad present
in the home seems to be one of the key
questions that needs to be asked in
terms of what is the evolution of that
child what's missing what's going on and
how is that impacting all of these big
picture issues that are happening around
the country and the last one which we
talk about economics all the time
children are four times more likely to
be in poverty from the lack of a father
in the home
so this is just reality right this isn't
you know
angling stuff oh we want to present a
certain perspective we want you know a
certain point of view to thrive so let's
no this is just the reality of what's
happening in this country right now and
these stats are startling
now i said there was an epidemic
that's true
think about again every issue on the
table right now throughout the country
almost every one of them that you care
about everything i don't care what it is
think about
would that issue be better or worse if
these stats didn't look like this
think about it
think about people you know do you know
people who grew up in a fatherless home
how did that impact them
ask them about it have those
conversations this is very very very
important stuff
and again
i remember hearing a conversation uh way
back
i was having a conversation with someone
actually now that i think of it about
this issue and i remember them saying to
me
women don't you don't need a guy
you don't need a guy to have a baby it's
not it's not necessary that's antiquated
and i said well first of all you do need
a guy to have a baby that's number one
and secondly
what a horrible message that is what a
horrible message that is that that child
could grow up in a world without a
father and that would just be
replaceable in some way
that's just not what happens that's not
what it looks like so let me tell you a
little bit about my life
i grew up in a house with a dad that was
very present my dad was uh my dad was
one of the reasons that i'm a badass
right now truthfully
he taught me from a very young age to
speak my mind i was a very shy kid they
kind of had to like pull me out of my
shell you're like jed come on
really honestly in the first grade i
think my mom always tells the story that
the teacher came to her and said does
she talk
and my mom was like she does but she's
really shy can you imagine could you
imagine you're like pull the mic away
tyler take it away cut her mic
um
but my dad was present my dad was the
guy who was on the sidelines when i was
running track cheering me on
he was the one giving me a reality check
too saying why are you saving that burst
of energy for the end you're being lazy
for the whole rest of the race and then
at the last hundred meters all of a
sudden you're dart you if you have that
much energy the energy at the end you're
not running the race right
he was the guy who um spent every
saturday in the library with me when i
was in high school doing papers and
teaching me how to research and teaching
me how to get that stuff done so that
when i got to columbia university it was
a piece of cake i was like i was doing
this in high school my dad taught me how
to do this in high school
he was very present this is not by the
way a slight at mom's we're going to do
a whole mom thing on mother's day
because mom's playing incredibly vital
my mom's my best friend in the world but
this is about dads today and i'm not
going to apologize for that because dads
are important dads deserve a day and
dads deserve a voice
so
my dad played that role and also we
butted heads a lot
we voted heads a lot we did not agree on
some things
but he taught me to be the type of kid
that would be able to go to him and
defend my point of view which is why i'm
able to sit here right now and go
head-to-head with people that i disagree
with it'd be a nicki freed whoever it
may be and i'm like no
that doesn't work that was training that
came from my dad from those book reports
from all of those days of doing all that
stuff all of that grind
and
you know
it's interesting because my dad's super
practical too
so
when i decided i wanted to go into
television i think he nearly swallowed
his tongue and he was like no please not
tv
he wanted me to get you know that
regular job with that 401k that
practical stuff that wasn't me so i had
to he raised me though to be the type of
person i sat down with him i remember
one day and i was like listen
i'm gonna do this it's gonna be fine
i gotta go get the pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow so don't worry chill
it's gonna happen whether you like it or
not
and he just in that moment i think he
had two sentiments one was oh dear lord
what's going to happen here and the
other was wow
i raised her to sit across the table
from me and go after something that's
hard
well done tony was patting himself on
the back that day
he's also the guy that i went to a lot
of times when i did want to talk about
dating and relationships that was those
were conversations of course i had with
my mom i had different conversations
with my mom but my dad would sit me down
if i was in a bad relationship and he
would be like
that's not how a man treats a woman
that's a boy
you need to know the difference between
a man and a boy this is not good for you
what's going on and here's why
so he taught me he's one of the reasons
why
i didn't put all the goods out there to
all the guys i had a lot of self-respect
for my body i was like you need to earn
it
you need to earn that from me you're
going to take me on a whole bunch of
dates you're going to prove that you're
worthy he instilled that in me as a
young woman
very very young and that was really
really important growing up in a place
like new york city where a lot of women
had a very different attitude in these
woke times of oh sexual freedom and
i wasn't raised that way he taught me
hold the goods back
self-respect
those are conversations i had with my
father
that's important
very very important
now let's get to my husband
jeremy jeremy is was a dad before he
became a dad
uh one of the first uh dates that i had
with jeremy no joke he was younger than
i was
he sat me down i think it was the first
date i'm not kidding he sat me down and
he was like well you know i want to be a
soccer dad
and i want a work bench in the garage he
was a young guy i was like what is going
on here that this young guy is schooling
me
he knew what he wanted he and he is
the most incredible father when i got up
in the middle of the night to to pump
milk i was br nursing hartley for the
first few months
he would get up with me he would get up
in the middle of the night he would wash
those bottles out he would
babe is there anything else you need he
would cook meals we are like partners
like this something needs to get done in
the house it's like who's going to do it
it's not like oh this is a mom task this
is a dad no it's like what needs to get
done
he is so present for that child every
single day and he's the one
who got him on a feeding schedule who
got him on a sleeping schedule he's the
one who with hartley falls down and
skins his knee i'm like
baby skin is blood i'm like you know i'm
that person jeremy's like he's gonna be
okay and we need to show him that he's
gonna be okay he's like papa you're fine
we call him little papa there's papa and
then there's the little papa
so
and he he has gotten so much strength
from my husband and so much he we took
him to soccer for the first time this
week and he saw that daddy was watching
him and he was like i'm gonna kick the
ball and i'm gonna do control and
it's so important i cannot imagine
how different my life would have been
and that's not again to say
i love my baby like
i'm all in on being his mom my mom was
an amazing mom she has my back through
thick and thin that's not saying i'm not
taken away from the moms here
i'm giving to the dads and
my whole life i don't know what that
would have looked like without my dad
i can't imagine i truly can't imagine
and i can't imagine my son's life
without jeremy in there because it's a
balance right and no one wants to say
that moms bring something to the table
and dads bring something to the table
and it's different
it's just different and together they
make a complete package for that child i
know someone's going to tell me you're
outdated you're a neanderthal
call me what you want it's the truth
it's the cold hard truth and you see in
the stats when you take a father out of
the home you see the problems that arise
there are reasons for that because dads
are bringing something that's that no
one else is and when i say a father
figure i mean you could have a grandpa
in the house too you know it's not every
family there are going to be different
types of families people are going to
suffer tragedies right
you're going to have a dad
god forbid that passes away you're going
to have a grandpa or an uncle step into
that role
i'm not knocking on any of those
families
what i'm saying is that there needs to
be a father figure in that house
there needs to be a father figure in
that house or
you run the risk of complications you
run the risk of consequences you
absolutely do
and i could twist those stats and i
could paint a pretty picture of unicorns
and rainbows but it's not real
and dads at home who are on the fence
who are like
i don't know i had a kid young have a
friend
had a kid really young and he was like i
don't know he went through a crisis of
conscience he was like i don't know if
i'm ready for this i don't know if i can
do this
i'm so proud of him because he came into
the understanding that that job was the
most important job he was ever gonna
have one
and it was also the most rewarding job
he was ever gonna have and he became a
man
through being a dad
and it was the most incredible thing to
watch so i want everyone listening who
might be like i don't know this is so
it's hard it's really hard but you have
the power to change somebody's life in
such a big way
so this is just my tribute to dads out
there to everyone out there who's you
know balancing a lot who's juggling a
lot who's who's in the home who's
present
for your kids
you don't even know what it's doing
today
but every positive thing in that kid's
life i guarantee you're going to trace
it back to the fact that you were there
that you were present and that you cared
enough to be there if you liked the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]